normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government this
is tweeted from Elon Musk he says fraud
has both civil and criminal penalties
Ken Paxton attorney general hasn't of
the great state of Texas has announced
an investigation into Media Matters for
potential fraud saying the Office of the
Attorney General is opening an
investigation into Media Matters for
potential fraudulent activity under the
Texas Bureau organizations's code and
deceptive Trade Practices Act the oag
will vigorously enforce against
nonprofits who commit fraudulent acts in
or affecting the state of Texas Attorney
General Paxton was extremely troubled by
the allegations that Media Matters a
radical anti-free speech organization
fraudulently manipulated Daton X
formerly known as Twitter quote we are
examining the issue closely to ensure
the public has not been deceived by the
schemes of radical left-wing
organizations who would like nothing
more than to limit free speech by
reducing participation in the Public
Square said attorney general Paxon
ladies and gentlemen come on there we go
tell me you are red you you are
blackpilled okay we are looking at a
major turn Ken Paxton of course I'm not
surprised to see him doing this this
dude means
business if Missouri follows suit
because they announced first they were
looking into it Paxton probably saw that
and was like hey man we're on board
announces is this potential criminal
invest a literal criminal investigation
poal criminal charges of the people at
Media Matters I got to say this mus IP
ban all Media Matters employees no
question if you want to argue Free
Speech I'll argue Free Speech if you
want to argue they disliked things that
were said argue things they they
disliked things but if you are saying
you have proof they manipulated the
platform for fraudulent activities you
are the judge and the jury here so I
think it's fair to say if you are using
a platform to engage in fraud criminal
and civil tort violations then you
should be banned martiny replied to that
tweet by Elon Musk and he just goes can
confirm I'm friends with him he's man
God has consequences he seems great he
is the man oh he's so funny on at least
on X I know a lot of people hate him I
think he's hilarious I think he's great
what's uh if this Media Matters gets
found guilty liable for fraud and
everything then what would they have to
pay out Dames criminal criminal crial is
like that's criminal I don't know who
person the people so what's going to
happen is with a a fraud investigation
for a charity they're not going to go
Media Matters committed fraud they're
going to say John Smith whoever the fake
name you know John Doe or Jane Doe said
these things fraudulently in an effort
to engage in these behaviors so they'll
take out the employees that committed
fraud will get their their criminal
filings and then the company itself is
it going to take a civil hit cuz it's
got 11 million in assets in
21 I I think this might be the end yeah
but like what stops just some new
operation from just kind of all they do
is just like follow 30 Twitter accounts
and and here's the issue with going up
against government Texas has effectively
unlimited funds yeah you're you're 11
million assets bro that that's that's
not enough to maintain a couple car
dealerships in 2021 was their their what
they had on hand was 11 million and so
what I imagine happening now is facing a
massive lwuit from Elon Musk and an
investigation from Ken Paxton they're
going to get buried in legal paperwork
they're not going to be able to afford
afford the lawyers they deserve it they
they've really really screwed the pooch
on this they went too far if they
actually doctored up images to get X um
well they just miss advertisers to leave
the company that is the issue is they
they didn't have to do it before but
they're desperate what what is happening
now with the narrative machine the the
neoliberal neoconservative unip party is
they are so desperate because they're
losing every day they have to engage in
more and more extreme activities it used
to be that they could make a phone call
to one of their cult members at Twitter
and they'd say okay we understand we'll
do as we're told the FBI right the FBI
calls up and says you know we just think
this shouldn't be there if you get our
drift like you got it boss now they're
calling Elon and he's like well actually
I'm the richest man in the world so I
got more you money than you can
imagine have a nice day and now they're
like what do we do there's nothing we
have elon's done nothing wrong so they
must now fabricate it and that's risky
and it's a losing strategy and they're
going to lose because of it and the
funny thing is they've been doing this
stuff for so long that probably never
cross anybody's mind that this was a bad
idea they've been just getting away with
this forever and they nobody probably
said hey this isn't maybe the best idea
to do this yeah it was like it was
incrementally getting worse well they
just have like probably have never had
any they've probably done this to tons
of companies right and just kept getting
they go yeah look how many companies we
shut down like it's works well a lot of
companies probably just say we'll we'll
do what you tell us media matter says
hey you said a naughty word and they go
okay fine we'll take it down because
it's easier than dealing with a lawsuit
yeah now they tried they they just
ripped away probably you know like half
a billion in ad Revenue potentially and
Twitter can prove it the funny thing is
these these companies don't get it
they're going to be on the hook for 500
million plus oh they'll just yeah
they'll go bankrupt they'll cease to
exist overnight Now Fair Point they will
start another one and try and reopen
another one but precedent is being set
if Republican AGS are now willing to go
after for criminal charges they will not
be able to spit up another company the
the basic strategy of hey elon's racist
didn't work yeah it didn't work anymore
it used to work it used to be hey elon's
racist and then the CEO be like no no no
no no no I'm not no I'm not Advertiser
threaten a boycott they'd say oh Mia cul
I'm so sorry and then everyone would say
okay now that you've pledged to the cult
you're free to go but that's not working
anymore Elon buys Twitter and laughs in
their faces so what do they do now they
have to take it to an extreme doctoring
a circumstance in order to try and get
advertisers to pull out and now it's
easily provable yo Discovery is going to
be a yeah yeah this is this will
be interesting to see if there's actual
criminal charges that it's be beyond
that Discovery may lead to Expo
government exposure yeah yeah I I'm
willing to bet you will find
Communications between Media Matters and
people in government no
question well I'd love to see who funds
them I'm just they're paying out six
million in wages in 2021 and I bet it's
like one guy getting a million bucks 1.6
million to the executives and then
another 6 million to other Sal you you
can actually you can look up you can
look up the salaries explicitly like you
can look up their the names and how much
money they I'm more interested in what
kind of like what do they produce you
know like what like if you even ask them
like what have you done it's the we call
out
rightwing they have a uh uh a a mission
statement on the uh so they're Community
notes basically they've been just
replaced by Community
notes like that's what you do is you
just start Community notes yeah but but
look Community notes is is real though
it can be manipulated Media Matters just
makes things up yeah no it's it's it's a
501c3 Progressive research and
information center dedicated to
comprehensively monitoring analyzing and
corrective conservative correcting
conservative misinformation in the US
media so it's literally a propaganda
outfit looking to do what it can to Har
people that have different opinions
digital snitching yeah I mean it's but
it's beyond that now because they went
out of their way to fake evidence it's I
mean
call that fabrication of evidence fraud
it's it's man Tores interference is
crazy enough right like if Phil and
Danny had a contract and then I went to
Phil and said cancel that contract with
a Danny or else that's torous
interference yeah they're doing that but
they're also fabricating evidence in
order to get away with it that's crazy
with one of the most high-profile to
thew put some people on blast the work
for the company this is in 2021 Angela
kuson is that how you pronounce your
president CE that guy like an anti- half
a million dollars that year I don't know
but he post he has like a history of
posting a bunch of racist stuff doesn't
he uh Ian if you go back far enough in
most people's Twitter and stuff you get
some some interesting stuff yeah you
don't want to see the conversations I
had at Taco Bell when I was
14 I don't know any of these people
David Brock is that the guy that founded
Media Matters in 2004 he's still the
chairman of the company made 300 Grand
yeah 20 for what yeah exactly being the
chair you guys find any misinformation
today I'll be around twice a year for 1
hour
keep looking guys there's lots of
misinformation out there you got to go
watch all the uh the right-wing media
and then it's like some job for someone
who just literally just watches Ben of
here all day is that M information
that's that's what they do literally yes
literally and then they get on the
internet and they're like a
about it what's your job really formal
reports and stuff like what's your job I
watch Ben Shapiro and I'm an
about it what more can you expect yeah
well I don't know how you guys could be
blackpilled I mean we're I I I I think
we're winning I and I I think the
important things to understand is this
on the battlefield when when you see the
enemy break ranks you don't say okay
we're done you say charge now more than
ever and you know what I want to say it
was a few weeks ago I said this and now
I what I think we're actually seeing is
the the the storming of the battlefield
all of these lawsuits these people
pushing back the pledges to sponsor uh
to buy ads on X this is everyone
basically saying we're winning full
speed and you know what feels like the
Cavalry going in to finish the route is
the government picking up the lawsuit
the Texas state government and who was
it Missouri state government is that who
said Missouri AG said he was looking
into it and AG is and AG of Texas
announced an investigation that's that's
the calvalry coming in oh that's the
writers of Rohan dude L ling up in the
hill and that light shining down I'm not
sure how the Battle of Helms Deep will
be won I'm not sure how accurate this is
but someone is tweeting that the judge
that will be hearing the Elon Musk
bombshell lawsuit against Media Matters
was appointed by Donald Trump judge Mark
T Pitman is the same Jud judge that
ordered the FDA to release the fizer
files oo oh it's going to get fun my are
there any nonpartisan like
misinformation Charities like are they
all just partisan all partisan all
partisan because misinformation was the
term misinformation in modern Parliament
has been created to say stuff that
doesn't line up with the official
narrative if it's misinformation it just
means things the government doesn't want
you to think thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast I L podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net